march is national nutrition month you
may be surprised at some ways that you
can eat right and eat healthy dietitian
courtney mccormick says consumer
priorities on nutrition they really
changed due to the pandemic a lot of
people took a different approach to the
types of food that they kept in their
kitchen mccormick says a lot of folks
they turn to a surprising place the
frozen food aisle
frozen meals have definitely come a long
way from those tv dinners there's been a
lot of innovation in frozen meals in the
past few years and you're seeing
companies really be more purposeful
around the nutrition profile of those
meals and really be purposeful around
the types of ingredients and foods that
are being included in them
mccormick adds the key to eating healthy
is to keep things simple balance out
your life as much as possible lots of
veggies so frozen mac and cheese from
stouffer's we're good right that's the
healthy
that's probably not as healthy no but
it's good isn't it that's the problem
it's balance balance